rob kardashian shows off his weight loss  from head to toe he's just you know  feeling better about himself the 29 year  old has been dropping the pounds since  he started dating fiancee blac Chyna and  now we're getting a good look at all of  his hard work check out this new pic Rob  posted to Instagram a full body shot and  he definitely looks slimmer for  comparison this is a pic Rob posted on  Instagram from a photo shoot he did with  Chyna back in February  Rob revealed he weighed 298 pounds at  the time since then he's lost more than  50 pounds and look at the side-by-side  he's wearing just about the same outfit  so the difference is really clear Rob  says his goal weight is 200 pounds  Congrats to Rob